an outpouring of support for medical  workers and those on the front line in  the battle against coronavirus a helping  hand to make sure they're protected or  to look after their little ones  a community pulling together to support  the most vulnerable a bike to eat to  make the weight a little more bearable a  message of solidarity  [Music]  a message of kindness  [Music]  the sing-along to raise morale to show  solidarity with other countries in their  time of need a round of applause to say  we can get through this  across Europe tens of millions of people  are pulling together like them the  European Parliament is doing its part  taking concrete action supporting people  communities and businesses through these  difficult times  [Music]